uh let me start with congratulations
Oppenheimer is um yeah it's kind of good
you know
thank you I'll start like that uh have
you seen it in iMac 70 millimeter
uh I saw it in London at the at the BFI
and it was it was incredible it was like
the first time I saw it on it was on
IMAX and the sound system there was was
incredible and um it was it was a great
experience I brought my parents with me
um
yeah what is it actually like for you
after spending so much time working on
the music and just you know diving deep
into a project like this sitting in a
movie theater especially like an iMac 70
millimeter presentation and like taking
it in do you when you listen to the
music do you ever hear things you're
like man I I should have tweaked that it
would have been better like this or do
you sort it can you just let go and say
this is great it works I'm so happy
no I I definitely go of that you like I
let go of that until the last day of the
dub and we're done you know that's
that's we do everything we can up to
that moment and you know when I'm I'm I
have these you know I have these great
collaborators and and with Chris you
know we're on the same page you know we
we we feel the same about the music and
and we we we're finished when we're done
so
it's incredibly rewarding for me to sit
there in the theater and just enjoy you
know that's that's that's why I love
working on on on these movies and why I
love working on on movies and because
it's always rewarding you know you put
so much of yourself into this you put so
much your view of your time and your you
know and in your um your your feelings
and and I see you want to feel like you
get something back and and that's you
know one of the one of the times when
you feel like it's you you're getting
something back so I love it
I have a ton of random questions for you
today so I'm just gonna jump on in um
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about being a composer in
Hollywood
um
well I think uh I think you know I think
I think for when I was a kid you know
before jumping into this job you know I
thought it was going to be you know I
thought it was like a very I had a very
romantic image of it you know so you're
sitting in your cabin and you're writing
all this music for yourself and then
it's done and you you send it somewhere
and then it gets you know they put it
into the movie uh and that image is is
is not really how it works out in
reality
um then fortunately for me I've been
able to finding these incredible I have
these incredible collaborators with so
it's it's a very respectful job you know
we're we're but we're you know we're
doing it together we we push each other
around like we're pushing the music
forward we're pushing the boundaries of
the music forward but you know it's it's
a very
um it's a very
you know it's the only the only thing
that works that's working against us is
is time so you know it's it's not and
and that a lot of people think that
music and time is not you know you can
you can take your you know they don't
understand a relationship that that um
you know there there is deadlines you
know
yeah I just spoke to Daniel about uh his
work on Ferrari and he told me he wrote
the score in like five days or something
crazy because it had to get done I'm
like I don't understand that no no I
don't know if I can do that that seems
uh terrifying yeah no it was I I
couldn't do it but anyway that's a whole
different thing but what is it like
actually because you worked with Nolan
for the first time on tenant what was it
like when he called you for not only
tenant but for this and said hey I have
a project maybe you want to do the music
like what are those calls like
well for tenant it was it was incredibly
uh surprising because I didn't I didn't
think you know I never thought that that
I would get the call like that
um but it was it was also extremely
exciting because I mean I love
everything it's done with with Jose both
on zamer and David Julian you know and
and I was a big fan of those movies and
the music so getting the chance to work
with Chris and and I think I think the
way that he works with music and his
movies is incredibly unique it's almost
like it's its own characters in in his
films and to be able to get an Insight
in his mind and see how that works and
so on tenet you know it was a great
experience and then after attendant we
kept in we kept in contact you know
we're watching movies we were talking
about them we were talking about music
but he is also kind of very is also a
little secretive of him so like he
doesn't talk about like hey I'm working
on this now we're like he's like so the
phone call is about reading scripts and
and it comes always comes out of the
blue so he's like hey you want to read
the script tomorrow for my new film and
and you had no idea where you're about
to get into and that but that's also the
exciting part of it
yeah um I spoke to Matt and Emily about
how Nolan approached them to be in the
movie and Emily had to read it at his
house and gave Matt the script for like
a night so he could read it the next
morning uh did he make you go to his
house
uh for tenant I read it at his house uh
for
um for Oppenheimer at the office you
know but you it's very much in person
you know and and I love that
the thing is like uh uh it has to be
weird though even for you when you go to
the office to read the script and you
know that like he knows you're reading
it at that time and like you know what I
mean like you're trying to digest it
um is it are you one of these people
that can read the script and sort of get
it all in like instantly or do you need
like would you do you like having more
time with it to more digest it
uh well I like the instant impression
that you get of when you see or hear
something or you read or something
um obviously that it's gonna change with
time but but I like you know immediately
that after reading the script and then
like never never read anything like it
honestly like it was you know you
immediately go into his head and into
his mind you know you're seeing the the
world through his eyes and with
immediate you know immediately I
understand that that's what the music
needs to feel like you need to channel
that complex genius personality through
so many different spectrums of music and
that that's kind of what I took away
from that first read
when you are reading it are you writing
down some initial impressions of what
you're feeling so you could sort of
remember that when you start composing
or is it sort of just you're reading it
and just taking it in and then you're
gonna you know what I mean right yeah no
I'm I'm just I'm just taking it in just
like if I would listen or watch
something I just
you know
sure I read that uh when Nolan came to
you he mentioned violin that that was
the instrument that he was thinking
about is it do you enjoy that when a
director gives you that kind of guidance
early on and then what was it like
thinking about the violin for writing
the music
yeah I love that you know I love any
kind of ideas
um and especially especially the idea of
the violin was was extremely exciting
for me because my wife is my wife Serena
Gomez and she's an incredible violinist
and to be able to work with her and
start off you know going to the studio
and experiment and just experiment with
the tones of the violin and the vibratos
and how to go from I think why Chris was
so excited about the violin was that
it's you know it's a fretless instrument
and you can go from
you can go from uh from a vibrato being
most beautiful romantic to in in a split
second change into something horrific
and Manic and neurotic and how to have
that and those Channel
um oppenheimer's personality that was
something that we're brought for
you ever sneak in references to other
scores the way that John Williams can do
it
I don't think anyone can do uh can do it
the way John Williams is doing but uh I
I I I I I don't actually know the way
that he does it but I I don't do it with
the you know intentionally but but maybe
if you tell me that that oh this sounds
like this you know but but I I didn't I
don't intentionally know
uh what are some of the sounds and
themes that people can look forward to
in the music of Oppenheimer
um well I think one thing that was that
was unique for this for this a couple
things that was unique with the score
was was obviously the the the the the
strengths and the violence but also the
performance of the violence and the
strings you know I I one of the first
things that Chris showed me was this uh
I went into visual effects meeting at
the IMAX then I saw I saw some of the
visuals that he had been working on with
Andrew Jackson and you see the spinning
of the atoms you know and that that
visual to me was just so spelled in The
Binding and I've never seen anything
like it and I was like that's how I want
the music to sound like and it was also
kind of scary because how do I get that
music to sound like that because it's I
know I wanted to work with Tempo and I
know I wanted to record it live with
with play with musicians but how to get
those Tempo increasements increasing
like that
doing it in one take and one Flawless
take was that was a challenge and we
implemented some a new recording uh
technique that I I didn't think was
humanely possible to play it but with
this incredible group of musicians we
were able to do it all these the these
Tempo changes all in one one one one one
take and you can hear it in um you know
in in the piece it starts with kind of
brown guy asking Kelly Murphy uh can you
hear the music and it starts off with
these um with these with this piece of
music
yeah I read that you did the recording
and I could be wrong like in this
intense five day period yeah is that was
that uh can you talk about that like
spending you know diving in for five
straight days or whatever you did to
yeah yeah we did I think it was it was
it was five to ten days of recording but
I think we spent just three days on on
figuring out how to record this this
Unique Piece of music with these
template changes 21 Tempo changes
starting from you know one temp one just
ending three times faster and doing it
all in one take and and I think that
human touch of it not because first I
was thinking we had to do it in separate
chunks but to do it all in one take uh
they really created that that chaos of
the spinning items and um yeah
which uh when I speak to a lot of of uh
composers directors they always talk
about how there's always something that
they continually go back to because
they're not a hundred percent happy was
there a piece of music in Oppenheimer
that you kept going back to because
you're like I think I can tweak it a
little bit more
um I think one I mean for us you know it
was
uh the one the one the last piece that
came to place was the the the music that
comes after after the bomb
um because it's it's you you don't it's
um
you really uh
the state that Oppenheimer is in is so
complex you know he's he's you know
you're thinking you've seen these people
you know you see these people sharing
but like what's he feeling inside you
know that that's and and
that took some time and that that we
worked on that uh that was the kind of
the last piece of the puzzle but other
than that you know I think for for the
movie you have you have the First Act of
the movie it's like it's it's come it's
these complex beautiful melodic intimate
violence and strengths and it's it's
it's it's it it starts off with this
beautiful
um intimate performance and ends in an
opera kind of and you're going through
that personal growth but then there's
the second act of the movie where in all
these theories and all these scribbles
actually you know it turns into an
actual product it turns into them into a
bomb and you see them actually you know
dealing with building it hoisting it up
and the whole music spectrum and the
color and tone the music changes in that
moment from from this organic live
instrumentation to just these three
sounds of like this pumping bass and
then and then you have this like little
ticking of a like a metallic ticking
um and that really propels you to you
know the the you know there there these
guys are about to blow themselves up you
know or they they could potentially
destroy the the man the the mankind
um
yeah
yeah uh this might be one of my last
questions because I'm almost out of time
uh and it's a more serious question uh
but one of the things that's going on in
Hollywood right now and one of the
reasons sag and wga are on strike is is
AI and I've been asking other composers
and a lot of people about their thoughts
on AI because it can be a tool for good
but it's also very scary because of what
it could mean
um are you when you think of AI are you
scared of it are you like what what's
your take on it and what it could mean
for your in for what you do in Hollywood
yeah I mean it's interesting I haven't I
haven't fully started using it yet in in
whatever I do but but I'm definitely
interested in in this looking you know
using it as a tool you know and I think
that's kind of what the conservation
conversation is about you can use it as
a tool but it's also but it would never
it would never substitute the Artistry
of people and the players and the
performers just like I said like I don't
want to described the scene you know
having that having those 70 people
performing that piece of music created
this breath and created this organic
sense of of chaos and and excitement and
and it's filling the room with air and
that's something if when we're already
feeling that filling room with air and
and and that's something that net will
never be able to um you can never
replace that and so I think you know as
long as you just hopefully you should
use it you know as a tool for yourself
yeah
totally my last thing for you actually
uh are you working on anything else now
or what's coming up for you
no I mean right now I'm just I'm I'm I'm
here I'm gonna watch a movie in New York
tomorrow and you know this was it was
this is uh you know it was a very like
it was such a
you know I loved working on this movie
and it was so it it spent I spent a lot
of time into it and a lot of my effort
and you know I feel like I'm I feel like
I learned something I feel like I'm
getting something back from it and right
now I just want to after I'm done I just
want to enjoy summer enjoy my time with
my kids and and just really you know you
know take some time and and uh so I
don't have anything down the pipeline it
just has to be the right thing
sir I'm a big fan of your work thank you
for giving me your time and uh listen
man Oppenheimer is fantastic I have
nothing but positive things to say
appreciate everything yeah I love your
questions so fun to talk to you and I
hope to do it soon again